bonsoir antoine le chef de la diplomatie
russe s'est exprimé au sujet de la
situation dans cette région à berne
oui tout à fait sophie sérieux lavrov a
dit espérer que les combats entre les
talibans et la résistance anti la haine
anti taliban dans cette partie de l'est
de l'afghanistan face bientôt place aux
pourparlers de paix le ministre russe a
également rappelé toute l'importance que
le dialogue se fasse avec toutes les
composantes du peuple afghan écoutez
en ce qui concerne les solutions pour
résoudre les problèmes de l'afghanistan
par des moyens pacifiques
je pense qu'elle existe j'espère que
maintenant les dernières vagues de
conflit dans le nord de l'afghanistan et
dans la vallée du panjshir ne cèderont
la place aux négociants
et les inévitables qu'un accord
politique comporte un compromis entre
les patchs ou non qui sont
principalement représentée par les
talibans même si d'autres patchoune
doivent également participer et les
tadjik les ouzbeks et les hazara il
s'agit donc de tous les principaux
groupes ethniques d'afghanistan inkster
chef des armées et nietzsche groupe à
winston
sarret lavrov qui a également laissé la
porte ouverte au dialogue avec les
taliban soulignant que parmi les
nouveaux hommes forts de kaboul eh bien
tous ne sont pas à mettre dans le même
panier écoutez
lorsqu'on dit qu'il est impossible de
communiquer avec eux l'a71 pièges du
diable il existe une décision du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies qui ne
reconnaît pas l'ensemble du mouvement
des talibans comme terroriste mais qui
sanctionne certains dirigeants talibans
pour des méfaits spécifiques notamment
des activités terroristes ou une
implication dans le trafic de drogue et
ses terrasses investir les chiens
et c'est dans ce contexte d'instabilité
en afghanistan que la russie ainsi que
ses alliés aux siens au sein de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective organise des exercices
militaires à partir du 7 septembre au
kirghizstan moscou qui compte des base
militaire au kirghizstan donc mais aussi
au tadjikistan pays voisins de
l'afghanistan et la russie qui assure
ainsi à ses alliés pouvoir répondre à
toute menace sécuritaire merci beaucoup
antoine gayraud depuis moscou fou